[Music]
Haley Baldwin used to love Jelena just
as much as believers did what do you
mean in a series of recently resurfaced
tweets dating back to 2011 Baldwin who
is now engaged to Justin Bieber gushed
over his relationship with ex alina
gomez in September 2011 she tweeted I
don't care what anyone says but Justin
Bieber and Selena Gomez together is the
definition of a teenage dream then in
January 2012 the future mrs. Bieber said
in a sense deleted tweet that Jelena was
the perfect couple
[Music]
but oh how the tables have turned
Justin pop the question to Haley in the
Bahamas just one month after rekindling
their romance the pair dated in 2015
he's just really sweet he's a good kid
it's a good heart and I love him
a source tells ET Stephen Baldwin's
daughter is over the moon with joy about
their engagement does your dad like him
not stupid question
both my parents liked him a lot another
source tells ET the pop star received
Stephens blessing before he asked Haley
to marry him adding quote Justin wanted
to respect tradition and show his future
father-in-law how serious he is about
his future with Haley our source says
Stephen is very happy for his daughter
and future son-in-law
my parents are incredible they're
amazing they're all supportive uncles
everybody there they have my back it's
great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]